a short time ago I spoke with the mayor
of Nashville John Cooper
Mr Mayor thank you for being here this
morning how's the town well yesterday
was our worst day
we've had challenges disasters in
Nashville but I think this was our worst
day this moment where we realized at
your own school children
in your schools have been subject to a
mass event
we've recovered we're resilient I think
we do a good job of supporting each
other but it was our worst day you
fought hard to get body cameras for
police officers they now have them have
you seen what was recorded on body
camera well I'm not seeing all of it I
don't know the department I'm sure if
they haven't last night this morning
will put it all out there but it's
extremely compelling of
officers rushing into gunfire there's a
lot of gunfire it's clearly a scene that
if they had not gotten there quickly it
would have been a terrible outcome tell
us more about what you saw in it well I
mean the body camera as we all know it's
a lot of jostling and a lot of moving in
but there's this sounds of guns the
sound of shooting there
marking each other's presence about
whether you are on your left on your
left the shooter purely has established
a
tactical position and then one of them
was able to take it out 14 minutes from
the call to the assailant being deceased
that's amazing even for our remarkable
group and it saved I think many lives I
know you spoke with the President
yesterday we'll have gun laws on the
agenda in that phone call well they were
not in that agenda the president is
saying reminding all of us that he has
had a lot of experience and he focused
on the Excellence of our Public Safety
response here too but also the mental
health the trauma the PTSD both for the
community and for the officers
themselves just your final thoughts for
your community well we need to love and
support each other there's a fund being
raised by the Community Foundation I put
it on all my social media platforms I
encourage everybody to put it there this
will raise money to pay for things like
funeral costs and helping families
through this time and counseling that
would be a very constructive way of
participating so just go online and post
it for other people the caring for
Covenant fund out of the Community
Foundation here in Nashville Mr Mayor
thank you thank you